Hollywood was once very niiiiiice to Sacha
Baron Cohen, the British comedian who broke
through in the U.S. with 2006’s Borat: Cultural
Learnings of America for Make Benefit Glorious
Nation of Kazakhstan.
"Welcome to our country."
"My name ah Borat."
"Ok, well, ah good good.
I'm not used to that but that's fine"
Centered around an often crude, sexist, racist
and naïve reporter from Kazakhstan, the comedy
opened up opportunities for Cohen to star
in a wide range of big movies like Talladega
Nights, The Dictator, Alice Through the Looking
Glass, Les Misérables and more.
But despite that string of roles, Baron Cohen
hasn't popped up on the big screen quite as
often as he once did — and here are a few
reasons why.
Family man
Unlike many of his peers, Baron Cohen doesn't
churn out multiple movies per year, and that's
by design.
Sacha and his wife, actress Isla Fisher, have
three young children, and they both want to
be active, present parents.
Cohen has committed to only making a movie
every couple of years, while Fisher plans
to only take supporting role until their kids
are fully grown.
While these Hollywood parents love to act,
it sounds like they're putting family first
— at least for a little while.
Real World Reputation
Even if Baron Cohen wanted to keep making
reality-blurring movies like Borat, he doesn't
think he could.
A victim of his own success, he fears he's
become too recognizable to pull off a movie
like Borat or Bruno again.
On top of that, there's also the matter of
the inherent danger in making those kinds
of movies, as Baron Cohen’s films have definitely
landed him in hot water in the past.
"The idea of the movie was actually to end
it with inciting a riot in Arkansas while
me and my co-star made out on stage."
He was lucky to get out of that one unharmed,
but even a minor, non-deadly stunt from Sacha
can end up being very stressful.
When Baron Cohen made a surprise appearance
as Ali G at the 2016 Academy Awards, people
were genuinely shocked — because the show
producers had specifically told him not to
do it.
This caused some stress for his wife, who
had to be complicit in the prank and even
smuggled the Ali G costume into the awards
ceremony under her dress.
She then had to help her husband get into
character backstage and lie to the producers
who were trying to figure out what he was
up to.
"So I was really stressed I was like 'Honey
honey this isn't gonna work' then I had to
go out finally and I said 'There is something
that is wrong with his stomach.
It's really bad.'
Fisher did what any reasonable person would
do after faking out 20 million people on live
TV; she hit the bar...
The Brothers Grimsby
Baron Cohen's last "big" movie was 2016's
The Brothers Grimsby.
Like some of Baron Cohen's previous films,
the mismatched spy comedy made headlines not
for its creativity, but more for it’s shockingly
crude moments.
The movie was wildly unsuccessful, both commercially
and critically as it really seems like almost
no one connected with this flick.
It was one of Baron Cohen's few leading roles
in a movie in which he didn't play a character
interacting with real life people — and
audiences just weren’t that into it.
One hit Wonder...
Between 2000 and 2004, Sacha Baron Cohen created
three main characters for his comedy series,
Da Ali G Show — Ali G, Borat and Bruno.
And by 2009, he’d brought all of them to
the big screen.
While Ali G Indahouse wasn't released theatrically
in the U.S., 2006’s Borat was a massive
hit, bringing in $128 million and earning
Baron Cohen and his collaborators an Oscar
nomination for screenwriting.
"This suit is black, purse, not"
In 2009, Baron Cohen brought his third and
final character, Bruno, to movie audiences,
but he was unable to recapture the magic of
Borat.
Bruno, a mockumentary about an openly gay,
fashion-obsessed Austrian weirdo seriously
underperformed, bringing in less than half
of what Borat did and undoubtedly slowing
down Baron Cohen’s rise to fame.
Breakthrough dramatic role
In 2010, it was announced that Baron Cohen
was considering starring as singer Freddie
Mercury — to whom he certainly bears a resemblance
— in a biopic about the late Queen frontman.
Baron Cohen was actively involved in trying
to get the movie off the ground, even consulting
major directors like David Fincher and Tom
Hooper.
But in 2013, he decided to pull out of the
project — and the film still hasn't been
made.
The actor claims he left the project because
the surviving members of Queen wanted the
movie to be a relatively tame biopic about
the entire band.
On the other hand, Baron Cohen wanted it to
be purely a Freddie Mercury movie showcasing
the late rock star's wild life.
Queen guitarist Brian May offered a different
opinion on the issue, suggesting that Baron
Cohen would have be a distraction, as he doubted
that the larger-than-life actor could actually
disappear into the role and do it justice.
What's next?
Well, we likely haven't heard the last of
Sacha Baron Cohen and it wouldn’t be surprising
if he’s working on another big character
right now.
From what we do know, Cohen has two main projects
in works the for the next few years.
The first is a timely bit of satire called
Greed, in which he plays a money-mad, financial
law-skirting billionaire.
The other is a big-budget film adaptation
of Mandrake the Magician, in which he'll star
as the title character, a heroic master of
illusion.
Seems like a good fit…
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!